from san jose in california brian
chastain joins us now at brandy chastain
oh it's really wonderful to speak to you
thank you so much for being with us this
morning here on sky news uh just first
of all your reaction to what you saw
last night at the lionesses winning the
cup well i i have to say i've been a big
fan of watching the euros this year and
just to see the amount of talent in this
tournament has been phenomenal
to know that 90 000 people sat in
wembley to watch women's football
obviously is a huge achievement for all
of these players
and when i saw the celebration of course
a big smile on my face and the thought
about how her life and the life of all
of those players for england will change
immediately um brought me great joy
yeah let's just see if we can bring up
the images of that celebration and of
course what you did back in 1999 i mean
just talk us through what happened after
you actually did that you took your show
up and celebrated
when the u.s women's team won i mean it
wasn't taken
in the best experience was it there was
a bit of criticism for your actions
i think there was mostly joy and mostly
acceptance but of course there's always
going to be somebody to say why did you
do that but that opened it up to a
wonderful conversation about the
importance and the validity and the need
for women's football to belong in the
big stage and so it was always a
wonderful discussion to have for me uh
always an opportunity to share the
greatness of the game
and to continue to further along women
in sports and
and our power and our strength that goes
along with the work that we put in just
like our male counterparts
yeah just amazing pictures brandy that
we're looking at right now uh of the
split screen of you in 99 and uh chloe
last night um now just just tell us the
us uh women's team is the most
successful women's team of all time am i
right in saying that
i mean how do the england team now after
that great victory last night sort of um
parlay that into into going on and
becoming a real force in world football
well i think
the fa has has given uh i think a
platform for this this team and serena
wegman to continue to do great work
obviously being you know at the top is
very difficult winning a tournament like
they they just did is incredibly
exhausting and all encompassing and so
going forward is going to be probably as
hard as it was to win this this match
but the fact that they've done it now is
is a feather in your cap that nobody can
take away number one
for them to be able to know that it's
possible number two gives great
confidence uh to move forward and
what it will have done for the countless
tens and maybe hundreds of thousands of
young girls in england is to give them
this dream that
it is possible for them and now the
future of um
[Music]
the women's league in england and around
the world we'll see that what we're
doing is absolutely
um
worthy and acceptable and we can now all
push forward so the win in england um is
good for everybody global football it's
incredibly powerful
yeah absolutely right let's talk then
about pay renumeration for this brandy
um i mean as you'll know the the us
women's team had to go to court to make
sure that they were paid equally with
the men's team the women seemed way more
successful and yet the men's team were
getting paid way more um
i mean how do the england footballers
try and make sure that they get paid
what they deserve to get paid after
winning an international tournament
again i think for us it was decades in
the making and this is not something
that happens overnight however
this this team has been around for quite
some time obviously the culture and the
tradition and history of football in
england
on the men's side speaks for itself um
even though you know winning winning a
european championship or winning the
world cup is not something that comes
extremely easily and and so
you know most countries don't
get to even experience what the english
women's national team just did and so
that that is a
reason enough to have the conversation
but also a shining example of why
there is great value in what they did
and that the fa and every other
federation within fifa
should see the value of that and
accordingly act in terms of
the
the monetary side of what these women
are doing
and finally then brandy thank you so
much for talking to us i just want if
you could tell us what advice would you
give to the to the to the girls this
morning i mean obviously when they take
an aspirin and have a glass of water
after celebrating last night what's your
advice to them to go forward from here
uh
to do so with great uh humility
and to you know spread the joy of
teamwork and
the determination and the hard work that
it took to get there uh the gratitude uh
to everybody who's helped them along the
way
you know it is to be grounded uh to stay
grounded and to stay in um
in the in the moment of the hard work
that it took to get there and and to to
win such a tournament is really valuable
and i i feel that that's been the fabric
of the us women's national team
that's been the fabric of the teams that
i've been around and been successful
with and i hope that each one of those
players will
take pause and really take in
what they have accomplished because it
is truly phenomenal and
you know i i i applaud each and every
one of them and say bravo and like i
said in the text um that i sent are the
twitter that i sent out to chloe kelly
and about the goal that ella tunes
scored that
we see you and we see the greatness that
you are
and keep doing and being who you are and
showing the world of football that
you can play too
absolutely right bravo from brandy's uh
is credited enough really appreciate
your time brandi chastain a world cup
winner thank you so much for being with
us
thank you so much too and
congratulations again
i'll pass it on to the girls